[Música]
hola buenas noches
yo les quiero platicar de que desde que
yo era pequeño quería saber que iba a
ser de grande creo que como casi todos
nosotros y lo primero que quise ser era
superhéroe porque veía las caricaturas
me encantaba la liga de la justicia
salía batman superman batman la mujer
maravilla y es bueno quise ser
superhéroe y un día con mi hermano el
mayor decidimos qué bueno queríamos
jugar a ser superhéroes entonces en un
brincolín que tenía mi papá subimos a mi
hermano chico de un lado nosotros
tendríamos 7 años 8 él tenía como 2 o 3
lo subimos pero no pensamos que iba a
pasar brincamos de un lado él salió
volando del otro el voló
y a partir de ese momento mis papás no
le gusto
que fuéramos superhéroes no nos dejaron
ser superhéroes entonces se acabó esa
carrera para mí
después los me gustaban los animales
también aparte de los superhéroes y tuve
muchísimos animales tenía perros gatos
serpientes peces porque los amaba me
encantaba tenerlos convivir con ellos
resulta en ese momento yo pensaba que
los amaba y mi mamá me decía hijo qué
quieres ser yo les ya quiero ser
veterinario sea hijo pero si cada que
algo le pasa algo de tus animales te
pones a llorar imagínate cuando llegue
la persona con su perrito y te diga
doctor por favor no llore doctor mi
perrito se está muriendo yo llorando y
era cierto yo creo que sí ahorita fue a
veterinario quiero tanto a los animales
que me pondría a llorar no tengo el
temple que tienen los veterinarios
también me gustaba el arte me gustaba
esculpir pintar me gustaba inventar
cosas antes no había lego había una cosa
que se llamaba tente era eran piezas no
eran como ahora que uno tiene que armar
un submarino tiene que armar a
determinada cosa una armaba lo que
quería y me encantaba inventar y hacer
cosas con ganchos con alambres con con
tela con muchas dos me gusta inventar y
terminé estudiando diseño industrial que
es una carrera donde uno puede hacer
cosas funcionales hacía muebles diseñaba
inventos diseñábamos partes de auto
sillas sillas de ruedas para personas
con capacidades diferentes con cosas
especiales otra parte tenía que haber
estética entonces junte ese gusto que
tenía por la estética por el arte con
inventar cosas y saliendo de la carrera
pues una empresa una empresa que hacía
justamente mobiliarios inventos teníamos
máquinas teníamos muchas cosas y de
repente se incendió en una navidad
y los socios que tenía que eran
compañeros de la escuela dejaron de ir
dejaron de ayudar y en ese momento tuve
que pagar todo lo que se había quemado
yo solo y desde ese momento la empresa
fue solo para mí entonces algo que
parecía negativo se convirtió en algo
bueno
la empresa fue para mí y creció la
empresa al mismo tiempo me seguían
gustando los animales un día vi un vídeo
de cómo trataban a los cerdos en las
granjas cómo vivían y cómo morían y yo
tenía un perro que se llamaba colchón lo
que vivió 18 años conmigo y de repente
yo sentí que pocho lo era igualito esos
cerdos alcancé a ver las articulaciones
de mi perro las patitas las orejas los
ojos y eran igualitas a las de los
cerdos y yo hice una conexión y dije
porque yo permitía este daño a esos
animales y porque cuido a este y porque
a los otros no qué pasa en mi cabeza y
por qué lo hice y ese día dije pues ya
no me los va a comer para no participar
en eso y después investigue las vacas y
las gallinas y entonces pues ya no me
los comía
había como más ayudarlos y dejé empecé a
investigar qué pasaba con los
espectáculos y en los circos y en los
delfinarios y tantas cosas que estamos
haciendo quiero ayudar
y busque organizaciones la primera que
busquen www.tu.tv de voluntariado
entonces acomodaba folletos ellos los
des acomodaban en la tarde para que yo
volviera a tener trabajo el otro día y
los volví a acomodar lo positivo de ella
era que yo leía todos los días los
folletos y aprendí mucho pero no estaba
salvando muchos animales entonces dije
voy a buscar a greenpeace que salvan
animales y yo quería ponerme en una
lancha y ponerme enfrente de los barcos
balleneros y que no les tirarán los
arpones y yo ser ese héroe no pero
resulta que no no lo puedo hacer primero
greenpeace no es que se dedica a salvar
animales están más sobre el medio
ambiente y pues otra es que lo hacen 34
personas y los demás nos están haciendo
muchas otras cosas pero yo quería hacer
eso y tampoco pude
leí en el periódico que iba a haber una
manifestación en contra de los circos
con animales en el auditorio nacional
porque venía el circo ringling brothers
dije pues voy a ir no son los animales
los vamos a defender y nos fuimos al
auditorio no sano nacional nos paramos
con unas pancartas y la gente nos
insultaba hubo algunos de los activistas
que insultaban a la gente de vuelta esa
parte no me gustó pero me gustó mucho
sentir que yo estaba haciendo algo por
ayudar y entonces por año sigue ayudando
a esa organización haciendo lo que me
pedían como tenía la empresa la empresa
y empezaba a hacer espectáculos eventos
grandes entonces les ponía audios hacía
que sus eventos funcionaran bien oa
veces me quitaba la ropa me ponía unas
banderillas falsas y nos tiraban los
cientos de personas en el suelo en el
agen de la independencia el monumento a
la revolución de noticias que salían en
todo el mundo para demostrar que era lo
que pasaba con los animales y hacíamos
ruido de todo lo que ocurría y así hacía
activismo hasta que un día me invitaron
a ser director de la organización se
habían quedado sin director y me dijeron
pues este ya es adulto y atender
yo no sé unos 30 y algo de años y misión
quiere ser director ejemplo o sea que
puede pasar soy director de mi empresa
tengo tiempo pues va a ser un hobby y
así fue un tiempo y fue muy muy
divertido
y luego nos pidieron hacer una campaña
que se llamaba circos sin animales y la
idea era tomar fotos de celebridades en
calzones así era la campaña y decía la
celebridad yo quiero un circo sin
animales
teníamos que buscar esas celebridades en
los otros países eran ocho los países
que tenía esa organización lo hicieron
aquí conseguimos cinco artistas entre
ellos marco antonio régil que de
inmediato dijo si yo ayudo porque le
gustaban los animales
ninguno salió en calzones cabe decir si
no estaría la foto de todos ellos por
ahí pero bueno no salieron en calzones
pero sí decían yo quiero circo cine
animales sólo que aquí en méxico a
diferencia de los otros países dijimos
no vamos a sacar la campaña hasta que no
haya una propuesta de qué sirve sacar en
redes a los artistas diciendo jokin un
circo sin animales sin una propuesta
y hay que hacer para prohibirlos pues
una iniciativa legislativa y cómo se
hace eso yo era un empresario y era
diseñador industrial no tenía la menor
idea nunca había hablado con una
celebridad con un político entonces pues
quién lo ha hecho abogados no esté pues
vamos a buscar abogados en redes
sociales
conseguimos abogados e hicieron
iniciativas presentamos en querétaro hoy
en ciudad de méxico en el año 2013
y logramos prohibir querétaro en
diciembre
no había nadie en ese momento incluso
fue unánime porque las mismas
celebridades los cinco que nos habían
apoyado entre ellos pati chapoy sofía
sisniega y otras celebridades más
hablaban directamente con los diputados
yo hablaba con el diputado le decía
señor que estamos buscando prohibir los
circos con animales y decía bueno es que
no sé por qué el empleo y tengo en la
línea marco antonio régil no bueno si
siempre ha estado de acuerdo y entonces
pos y vamos logrando así logramos la
unanimidad se prohibió en querétaro a
partir de eso se hizo una bola de nieve
y estado tras estado y vamos prohibiendo
yo tenía que viajar a todos esos estados
a hablar con los políticos a hablar con
los medios a dar entrevistas y era una
vida maravillosa al mismo tiempo tenía
una empresa que como iba subiendo el
activismo iba bajando la empresa porque
yo no le ponía atención
a parte de la empresa resulta que a los
cirqueros no les estaba gustando lo que
ocurría y yo lo entiendo se les estaba
cambiando el modo de vida ellos no
entendían lo que estaba pasando no
estaban de acuerdo y empezaron las
amenazas en ese tiempo yo tenía mis
redes sociales abiertas como muchos
tenemos o teníamos antes ahora con la
seguridad no se hace pero yo las tenía
así y ellos descubrieron que yo tenía un
hijo de dos años y entonces vinieron las
amenazas no sólo contra mí sino contra
mi familia contra mis amigos y contra mi
hijo mi familia se fue de méxico porque
no podían con ese miedo no estábamos
acostumbrados a ello que iba a salvar
animales era algo bonito era algo que
pues todo mundo iba a disfrutar pero
resulta que no que había intereses
entonces se fue mi familia y yo me quedé
viviendo en mi empresa tenía como 50
trabajadores y tenía mi oficina y mi
oficina en un espacio más o menos como
este donde tenía mi escritorio un
pequeño refrigerador tenía una parrilla
donde me calentaba la comida un medio
baño entonces tenía un hervidor a
trabajaba para empresas que hacían
electrodomésticos tenía un hervidor y
todos los días calentaba mi agua le
echaba la cubeta y me bañaba
tenía una sala donde levantaba los
sillones y sacaba cobijas y las ponía en
el suelo quitaba mi mesa del centro y me
dormía y todos los días y eso me hacía
feliz estaba bien necesitando poco lo
que sí era duro y era triste era
escuchar a mi familia escuchar a mis
amigos ya mí mismo decirme qué estás
haciendo estás destruyendo tu vida
tenías todo viajabas tenía sueldo tenías
empleados y hoy estás destruyendo todo
ya no tenía casi nada se había ido mi
familia no tenía nada estaba literal
durmiendo en el piso bañándome a
jicarazos que tengo que hacer sigo con
esto sigo con el activismo sigo con mi
empresa
y me di cuenta que era lo que me hacía
feliz y me di cuenta que estaba rodeado
de personas de abogados de diseñadores
de comunicólogos que estaban dispuestos
a dar su tiempo su vida sus
conocimientos para ayudar a otros que ni
siquiera tenían la voz para pedir ayuda
para defenderse estaban dispuestos a dar
su vida por eso como yo dije quiero
dedicarme a esto quiero ser un héroe
para los animales la organización donde
estábamos no quería hacer un plan en el
que los activistas pudieran tener un
sueldo como en cualquier organización
del mundo común y ser como cruz roja no
querían hacer esto y dijimos vamos a
hacer nuestra propia organización y le
vamos a poner animal giros héroes para
los animales y no porque nosotros
fuéramos héroes queríamos invitar a la
gente a ser héroe por la causa que fuera
a sumarse en este caso por los animales
a partir de que lo logramos de que
hicimos esta organización
hemos logrado prohibir circos con
animales en 15 estados todo tipo de
animales animal
a nivel federal todos los animales
silvestres están prohibidos no se pueden
usar en circos hay cuatro estados que ya
no tienen corridas de toros hay dos
estados más que no tienen peleas de
gallos en casi todo el país el maltrato
animal es delito quien sea cruel con un
animal se va a la cárcel y vamos
logrando más y más y más y mi idea de
platicarles todo esto es invitarlos a
ser héroes por la causa que ustedes
quieran y hay cuatro pasos que yo
encuentro para ser héroes lo primero es
que tenemos que aprender a restar a
quitarnos todo lo que no nos sirve para
hacer esas personas que queremos ser no
nos sirven todas esas personas sean
amigos familia lo que sea que están
diciendo no se puede tus sueños no se
puede lograr claro que se puede
necesitamos creer que se puede quitarnos
de eso no significa bloquear esa gente
no significa dejarla de amar ni ni me
sacarla de nuestra vida
significa
esta parte restarnos de eso restarnos de
distractores como esta televisión que de
repente estamos viendo y no nos aporta
como las redes sociales en la parte que
no nos aportan porque también tienen
cosas muy útiles por ejemplo estas
pláticas las vemos en redes sociales y
en la televisión y nos aportan
necesitamos eso pero necesitamos
quitarnos todo lo que no nos sirve todos
los malos hábitos como no tener
disciplina como no ser no estar luchando
por ser esos que queremos ser quitarnos
todo eso luego después de restar tenemos
que aprender a sumar tenemos que
sumarnos de gente importante de gente
que sí nos aporte somos el promedio de
la gente que nos rodea
tenemos que rodearnos de gente que
admiremos de gente que sí hace lo que
nosotros queremos hacer de gente
disciplinada gente que come bien tenemos
que tener esos buenos hábitos juntarnos
con gente que valga la pena ver
contenidos que valgan la pena
después de sumar y restar tenemos que
dividir porque cuando vemos un problema
creemos que es imposible por ejemplo el
mundo está terrible como lo arreglo no
tengo idea y yo soy este pequeño aquí
que no lo puede arreglar pero qué tal si
de todos los problemas del mundo escojo
los animales y qué tal si de el problema
de los animales escojo educar y legislar
eso si puedo y entonces ya es posible
que yo haga algo porque dividí mi
problema y lo último y lo más importante
para ser superhéroes es multiplicar
todavía no tenemos el superpoder de
podernos clonar y hacer hacer varios de
nosotros para lograr cosas entonces la
única manera de multiplicar es unirnos a
más personas ese abogado que sólo sabe
hacer leyes según el comunicólogo que
sabe comunicar lo que se une a la
celebridad que llega a millones de
personas y al biólogo que nos está
asesorando y a tanta gente unida que
sola no hubiera logrado nada estas
celebridades dentro de sus televisoras
quizás no podrían hacer nada pero unidas
a las organizaciones que les dan cosas
lo pueden lograr entonces la forma de
que cualquiera que quiera cambiar a
méxico puede lograr cosas es uniéndose
organizaciones o creando organizaciones
a veces pensamos que podemos poner un
granito de arena para cambiar el mundo
pero no es suficiente
yo puedo no tirar basura y enseñar a mi
hijo a que no tire basura la cuestión
está en que quien más le están tirando y
yo no la tire pero su basura tapó mi
coladera y su basura contaminó mi
planeta no sirvió que yo no la limpiará
tenemos que limpiar
y limpiarla de social o hacer algo para
que ellos no la tiren pero tenemos que
hacer algo porque si no nuestro propio
mundo se va acabando todos queremos
cambiar a méxico todos queremos cambiar
al mundo pero pocos hacen algo el
'informe país que habla de la calidad de
la ciudadanía dice que un 2% de la
población trabaja con organizaciones
civiles o las apoya 2% y eso incluye
partidos políticos y religiones donde
está la mayoría de la gente que ayuda
trabajando por el cáncer por la
naturaleza por los animales o por
cualquier otro causa hay muy poquita
gente y la gente puede decir bueno es
que no tengo tiempo es que trabajo es
que tengo familia es que pues yo no
quiero ser como antonio y estar viviendo
en una oficina yo no quiero que me
amenacen y está muy bien pero esos
superhéroes batman superman la mujer
maravilla trabajaban en un lugar en la
liga de la justicia que seguro no
pusieron ellos alguien lo puso para que
pudieran trabajar
los activistas todos los superhéroes
necesitan un lugar para trabajar
necesitan poder moverse necesitan lograr
eso lo logra la gente que si no está
siendo voluntaria puede apoyar todos
podemos hacer una diferencia y apoyar
organizaciones la que ustedes quieran
pero decir no hago nada porque no tengo
tiempo y aparte no los apoyo porque no
confío por lo que sea no ayuda tenemos
que cambiar el mundo si puede cambiar
nosotros tenemos poderes y tenemos que
reconocerlo si podemos ser superhéroes
yo he tratado de serlo de niño quería
hacerlo hoy creo estarlo logrando y
quiero invitar a que todos ustedes sean
superhéroes por la causa que ustedes
quieran
[Aplausos]
[Música]